what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so a lot of you guys really seem to
enjoy these origins for injustice too
but Atrocitus is going to be a little
bit different here and the reason why is
because this video really dis origin as
we see it here is very much a part of
Geoff Johns Green Lantern mythos and so
what I'm going to do is I want to tag
this in both the Geoff Johns Rida
Lantern playlist and the injustice to
playlist so if you happen to come across
this and the Green Lantern videos and
you'll understand why it's here but why
I'm talking about injustice so with
regards situate rastas and really a lot
of the characters something I want to
reiterate from when we first you know
started talking about Brainiac was that
not every character in injustice is the
new 52 counterpart but a lot of them are
innocence of their origins are similar
but there are a few changes here in
there the issue is that in injustice we
never really got origins for those
characters they were simply just there
and again a lot of it was because of the
fact that it was the Justice League and
so you know we could just kind of take
the state to hear it with a grain of
salt assume their origins were almost
identical and pretty much go forward
plus the story wasn't really about their
origin so much as it was about them just
fighting each other and you know
becoming evil and so on and so forth but
the fact remains here Atrocitus is a new
introduction to the injustice mythos and
he is probably one of my favorite
characters I love the Red Lantern fourth
Reds probably my favorite just because
of the fact they're just evil man
like you're just just evil like they're
just bad people and and it's kind of
cool to see the whole thing unfold but
the good thing about this is that with
this origin it's just as much a part of
the Green Lantern mythos as it is about
Atrocitus himself so what this does is
this picks up on the planet Ryu tour
Riyadh I'm not sure exactly how you
pronounce of Thomas every year just cuz
I think it sounds better
subtle agree you but um this basically
picks up with the Manhunters now the
most thing odds who are new to the Green
Lantern mythos and again we cover Green
Lantern stuff every Sunday or right now
we're doing Infinite Crisis which goes
into Green Lantern's we're doing that
every Sunday the Manhunters were
basically the guardians of the universe
first attempt to create a police force
within the universe in the sense that
once they basically disbanded a motion
for themselves they created the
Manhunters as androids to carry out and
keep order across the cosmos
now force on Planet Ryu this is very
much a major role for the character of
Atrios or I guess a choice how we want
to pronounce it who essentially has a
wife and kids and again for him it's
really just life
as usual he literally have a whole lot
of pause for concern his daughter takes
notice of the fact that the Manhunters
seemed to be a little more similar than
they were before but coming from you
know in adult perspective this really
seems to be a byproduct of a child's
imagination the reason why is because
otros basically says what these are
Androids they don't have a motion they
have programming they do with their
programming and tails which is actually
really kind of cool and really true for
example if you guys ever read a book
called how the mind works by Steven
Pinker he basically runs over why it is
that Skynet couldn't happen but the idea
here is that there's actually truth to
the words of eight roses daughter in the
sense that the Manhunters are actually
going awry now the Manhunters are still
robots the Manhunters do still have
programming but it's more of a glitch
than anything else is not only the
Manhunters became sentient organisms as
something to the Manhunters carry out a
task assigned to them by somebody else
if that programming is screwed up they
will become villains now what they do by
virtue of their programming being
screwed up which is actually done by a
guy named Crona we end up finding that
out later on down the line the
Manhunters begin going on a campaign
killing off everybody on this planet
every every single person the reason why
is because to the Manhunters modified
programming organisms that have free
will will use that free will to engage
in contradictory actions for example
warfare you know people who value life
in turn wage war against one another
which results in a loss of life so
because of that these various beings
much like normal humans are
contradictory you know how can you say
that we want to continue living when
they're moving ever closer to their own
extinction
through conventional and advanced forms
of war and so because of this the
Manhunters basically obliterated all of
them now it wasn't just Ryu this
happened all across the cosmos but the
issue is that within this sector 666
which is really more of like a demon
realm so just be kind of like a dark
magic section of the universe the result
is that both the wife and the daughter
of eight rows are completely destroyed
now at this point we start picking up
with the introduction of these sort of
demon entities and what these beings do
or at least what these individuals do is
they kind of Delvin really what passes
for black magic in the realm of DC
Comics as far as like spacefaring races
and their own brand or powers or so on
and so forth go but what they do is they
approach a trios calling themselves
really like the four demons now these
individuals were looked down upon and
banished by the guardians but with the
rampage taking place across sector six
six six what it does is it allows the
to rise to prominence once more now with
regards to Atrios himself he's filled
with absolute rage and that's why this
is so cool is because it's a person that
lost their family and something that's
really interesting about this is that I
would surmise truth be told I would
surmise that injustice one it would have
made more sense for Superman to become a
Red Lantern as opposed to a yellow
lantern but at the time it was just kind
of building on the mythos as it existed
and really even then the red lanterns
were still such a relatively new concept
it made more sense to use the Green
Lantern's and the Sinestro Corps instead
of the Red Lantern Corps just because
the Sinestro Corps was so popular back
then so even if only for the sake of
just good storytelling and drawing
people in this one estriol corps was
used but the implication here or the
similarities between a trough and
Superman and injustice are astounding
and to simply remember in the injustice
story
Superman lost his mind he went crazy
started going on a rampage and sent the
world into a state of complete and total
totalitarian rule because of the fact
that the Joker tricked him into killing
his wife and unborn child tricked him
into killing Lois Lane but at Rose is a
little different just because of the
fact that is an external force that
resulted in the annihilation of his
family but the end result is still the
same they've lost the people that they
care about how they respond to it is
entirely different that's one of the
cool things here is because one of the
things you'll find in comics is there's
a lot of similarities between characters
as they exist you know with regards to
their origin stories and so on and so
forth but the doctor mains here that
these these demons approach a chose to
say look you're a man filled with rage
you've literally gone on a rampage and
killed so many man hunters we want to
give you the power to organize us and so
this is when they really look to him not
necessarily as a leader but as a kind of
rallying point and I know it seems like
semantics but it's actually not a leader
role was the person who basically says
here are the things that we're going to
do here are the goals are going to carry
out with regards to these four demons
their minds aren't cohesive their minds
don't function in a true capacity
innocence they basically wander around
they don't have focused what they're
hoping is that through his rage HR else
would be the one that's able to
basically organize them to keep their
minds together and say we have to keep
our eyes on the prize so again it's
really more of like a rallying point as
opposed to you know an actual
traditional leader of source now what
this does is it allows you know a choice
and the script being agree identified as
the five inversions it allows them
spend several millennia traveling around
the universe waging war against all the
Manhunters and even the Guardians
themselves but that's really the crux of
the hatred of Atrocitus is the fact that
for him
it's really the Guardians who set this
thing in motion the Guardians created
the Manhunters the Guardians allowed the
Manhunters to continue existing even
after the massacre of sector 686 the
Guardians are the ones behind all this
and so the goal of Atrocitus is to
annihilate the Manhunters in their
entirety and annihilate you know the
guardian end of themselves now the path
to Atrocitus
becoming the Red Lantern picks up when
he basically begins speaking or at least
tries to speak again with one of the
members of the inversions a woman named
uh named Roy you more rocks team I'm not
really sure how you pronounce it I'm not
very good in French I actually failed
that class in college so I have no idea
exactly how you pronounce that but we're
going to call her rocks we're gonna
color Roxton I've seen that's pretty
much the way to say it but what we find
out is that between the time when they
first began their crusade to annihilate
these man hunters up until the present
day that Atrocitus that constantly
approached rock soon for the purpose of
learning blood magic in the sense that
it would allow him to see the future now
the issue here is that rocks tom says
look if you do this it will drive you
insane soon your entire life into a
tailspin the future is something that
you should not dabble in that you should
not mess with now the irony about this
is that ultimately Atrocitus basically
trickster Atrocitus says you know well
the whole reason why I'm here in the
first place the whole reason why I want
to learn the whole reason why we're so
close is because I love you so it's
really just him kind of spewing what he
needs to say in order to get the result
that he wants now something else is
interesting here is again he's really
following the trend of Superman and
injustice just tumbling further down the
rabbit hole to the point that he loses
all semblance of himself now the
difference here is that Superman's
morality was so incorruptible before he
lost his mind and allowed himself to be
corrupted that even when he became a bad
guy came up he became a bad guy only
insofar that he felt like he was doing
the right thing he felt like he was
saving the world so there was still a
measure of morality there but he was
basically kind of pushing that nagging
voice in the back of his head away and
saying I'm doing the right thing with
Atrocitus he just wants to wipe out the
Guardians it's a far more basic far more
visceral emotion it's an emotion of rage
but it's one that guides his
every waking thought and every sleeping
dream and so because of this what he
ends up doing is he basically you know
has a getting together of sorts let your
imagination run wild on that with
regards to rock soup and she basically
teaches on blood matching and what she
says is that in order to see the future
you have to basically use the blood of
others feed on your own rage and then
see what the future has to offer so of
course stealing your I guess kidnapping
one of the guardians he does exactly
that and what he sees is the death of
the other four inversions with himself
standing solo so again it's really him
seeing these events unfold and what it
does is it begs the question is this
future guaranteed and what I mean by
that is one of the funny things that
that people deal with when it comes to
the idea of like seeing the future in
comics is is that future guaranteed if
it is then no matter what you do it will
always lead to that future so for
example if you were standing at a fork
in the road and you were considering
going right but you wanted to look at
the future and see what direction you
were going to go in and you end up
seeing in the future that you end up
going left well then the question is did
you influence your own choice are you
the reason why you ended up going left
in the future as opposed to going right
because you saw what the future had to
offer the future change your position
even then if that's the case is every
decision you make ever you're going to
guarantee the future that you saw for
yourself so again it's really kind of
weird here but the fact remains that
over the course of their campaigns
eventually they're captured by the
guardians of the universe and they're
basically held prisoner on the planet is
small now once they're held captive here
Atrocitus managed to free himself and
then kills the other four inversions
just like he saw in his own future and
so because of that in the midst of his
rage and in the midst of his of his
wrath what he does is he taps into the
rage emotion from the emotional spectrum
and what it does is it basically spits
out a lantern to him and allows him to
basically form his own central power
battery and so what is up happening here
is Atrocitus uses the emotion of rage to
power himself and the result is that he
fires up a second blood prophecy and
looks into the future only to see that
he's basically going to form his own Red
Lantern Corps so again the origin of
Atrocitus is really pretty
straightforward here especially just a
guy whose family was destroyed when the
Manhunters you know formed by the
guardians of the universe went awry and
the result was that he especially just
started waging a war against them filled
with the dark side tapped into the dark
side he he became Darth Vader fell to
the dark side
learn to tap into the rage aspect of the
emotional spectrum and that really set
them on as an honest collision course
performing the Red Lantern Corps but
again just a pretty straightforward
origin pretty quick pretty simple
nothing too major here but if you guys
are new here the Commons explain make
sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the rock or if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
Oh
you
[Music]